[Music]
hello YouTube just lovers in my friends
this is Gungan here
welcome to the 21st episode of not each
Astrix now the Petroff or the russian
defense which arises after the water
evil 'if i Knight to f3 and now Knight
to f6 which is considered as one of the
most reliable and the solid defense from
the black it has been used at the
highest level to get a comfortable
equality or maybe a draw and not only
that at the lower level you are only
going to meet this when you're facing a
lower seeded upon it so that's why as a
white you should have a good replica
against it
now the setup I'm going to recommend in
this video not only contains lots of
tricks but the good point is even though
if you open doesn't fall for it wide get
slight consistent advantage here i'm
recommending white should certainly
follow the main line with the Moon
Knight captures ePHI and now Knight
captures efore is a famous mistakes so
that's why the main line run with the
moon d6 Knight to f3 and now black
regain his pawn with the move Knight
catches a 4 here white has tried few
options for example male line runs with
the Moody 4 there's also Knight to c3
which recently more popularized but I'm
going to recommend lasker or the cosy
attack
starting with the move Queen to e2 so
black responses force black has to play
Queen to e7 and we reach to a very
unique scenario where both the side has
blocked up that King side Bishop so it's
very obvious that in the most of the
cases they are going to castle on the
Queen side here I should continue with
the mood d3 hitting the night and after
the move Knight to f6 White has tried
many of
including Bishop to g5 now as usual we
are always going to shock our opponent
and Here I am going to recommend a very
tricky move starting with Bishop to e3
so not only they are activating the
bishop but we are stopping the Queen
trade now amazingly enough when I check
this position in the online database I
found out that this position has only
occurred in 12 games so you can
understand the surprise value of this
move black is in a crossroad now and he
has to decide amongst two plants which
one he is going to follow the first plan
is very obvious black is going to play
g6 - of g7 and castle on the Kings side
and the second plan is taking out this
Queen side piece and castle on the Queen
side considering the opening choice I
think Petrov player will hardly consider
the move g6
because they are not familiar with the
fianchetto setup however I have included
a simple line in the PGN which is
available in description which will give
you a very good idea how white should
proceed and get a good advantage against
this line the more neutral for the black
layer is to finish a screen side
development such as Knight to c6 and
after white continue with the moon
Knight to c3 they are going to play the
move Bishop to g4 so not only pinning
that night but black is all set to
castle on the Queen side with a
wonderful position well
wide response is very obvious why it has
to unpin this Knight as quickly as
possible
with the MU s3 now if you open and
surrender the bishop pair with the move
Bishop captures f3 or Bishop to a5
then Y should be delighted because in
the open game bishop pair is one of the
major factor we are going to look at
those lines at the end but first I want
to show you what happens if you opponent
played Bishop 2 at 5 because it looks
very natural preserving the bishop pair
and maintaining the pin well everything
look so good except one problem that
black has straightaway fallen into the
white tricky camp the tricky business
starts with the mood G for hitting the
bishop and after the move Bishop to g6
that Jeep on rolling down one more
square with the mood G Phi hitting the
night and now no matter wherever this
night goes white we locked in a winning
edge just early in the opening
I have reached this position six times
in my game and in five cases my opponent
has tried the move Knight to d7 but I'm
afraid this is a big time mistake
because now by force white can't win
blacks Queen here I should continue with
the move Knight to d5 hitting the Queen
and kindly note Queen has the only space
to go that is d8 and after that I want
you to pause this video and find out how
by force you can win black Queen okay I
hope you find this wonderful move BAM
with two district lines if Queen kept to
c7 then this is very easy because we can
deliver this discover check with the
move Bishop to b6 and nabbing the black
queen more critical is what happens if
King comes forward but then again we can
play the move Bishop to b6 discover
attack to the King and after any Knight
moves which blocks the diagonals let's
say Knight D to e Phi then we have this
night jack which again trap the baby so
you should remember this Queen trap
where if you open in place Knight to d7
then by force you can win the queen with
the move Knight to d5
let's see what we should do if you open
in place at the ninth move the first
more I want to consider is Knight to h5
so black has already put that night in
the corner and the best way to exploit
this is to start with the move Knight to
match for whites idea is when black
plays the obvious move castle on the
Queen side white will play the move
Bishop to g2 and now there are two
threats which I'm afraid black cannot
bury both of them in one blitz game my
2100 rated opponent continued with the
move Queen to d7 so his idea is to
protecting the night and then Devon off
his dark squared Bishop but White's next
move Bishop to f3 and he realized that
he just lost piece at the 14th move of
the game the more accurate mordor over
here is f 6 but then white can take the
snide and after pawn captures already
black skiing protection is shattered and
top of everything white has this move in
the picture that is Queen Jack kindly
note Queen to d7 can be easily met with
the move Queen to e4 so in one game
my opponent try the move King to b8 but
then white immediately concentrate on
the King with the move Queen check King
to eight then now Queen to h5
threatening a checkmate so black has to
stop it with the mu C Phi probably here
black has only considered the move
Knight to be Phi where he can defend
everything with the move c6 but what he
missed is after Knight captures pawn
captures and the move before black
position is completely crumbling he
tried the most c6 stopping any Knight
intrusion but after pawn captures
doesn't matter how black respond for
example in the game he responded with
the move he kept a c5 but then white
continued his attack with the move rook
to be won and now I think there is no
stopping with the night coming on the g6
square
just to demonstrate how quickly black
fallen apart my opponent continued with
the move rook to b8 I capture this rogue
dr. King takes a very strong move King
to D do so not only unpinning the bishop
but the rope comes into the frame
immediately my opponent tried to weather
the storm with the MU King to c8 but
it's never going to happen because after
rook to be one Queen to c7 try to
exchange the Queen Queen check King to
d8 and now rook to be seven attacking
the Queen Queen to ca and after Queen
catches a7
it's a pathetic position for the black
not only his King side pieces are
completely sleeping but on top of
everything White has a look to be a
threat
probably the third and the best choice
for the black over here is night going
back to g8 but nevertheless quite still
obtain a winning gauge after light to
defy hitting the Queen this time around
Queen has a hiding square in the move
Queen to d7 but as usual in this line
might never run out of the tactics and
here the star mu yep Bishop to b6
discover attack to the King kindly note
if any piece comes into the e-file then
Knight to c7 is a winning stem for the
white so black has to forcefully play
over here King to d8 afterwards we are
going to continue with the move Knight
to c7 hitting the rook and that fruit
cannot move for example in one game a
2100 rated player try the move rook to
c8 hitting the night but then comes
Knight to e6 double discover check black
has to forcefully move the King he
played King to e7 now comes another
discover check and after the Moon Knight
to e5 I simply took this Knight and
white is on the verge of creating
another discovered deadly check my
opponent tried Queen to e4 but after
Knight to c4 it is very obvious that
white is going to have a lot of fun in
this line
he tried king to d7 Quinn to g4 check
King to c6 and now I finish him at the
center of the board with this mortar
that is Queen check King to defy Bishop
to g2 Bishop to e4 and now Bishop
captures efore finished with a
picturesque checkmate so here it's very
obvious that black cannot move the rook
the baseline goes with the move pawn
captures b6 but then white can take this
route so already White is an exchange
herb and the only move to keep black in
the game which I doubt your opponent can
find out that is
Queen to f5 so black has a cunning idea
of Queen - if I check and nabbing the
piece but nevertheless White has a
decent reply over here that is b4 so
stopping all the nuisance the best line
runs with the Moon Knight captures
before but then white can continue with
the move rook to be one attacking denied
Queen to e5 trying to get a Discoverer
check so why it needs to block it with
the move Queen to d2 and after Knight
checked and came to Devon it blacks
takes the piece then his own Knight
hangs so the base response goes over
here with the move Queen to defy hitting
tonight but amazingly enough white has
this wonderful resource
Knight to be six hitting the Queen at
first sight it looks very strange
because after Queen check black and nab
the rook in the corner but believe it or
not this is exactly white once because
after King takes Queen takes and Queen
to e5 white obtained a very decisive
advantage let me fast forward few moves
Queen to c6 check King to d2 and now
however black plays his King is not
going to survive longer for example in
the situation base mu is Knight to e7
but then white can play the move rook to
c1 and black has to give up the Queen as
if he try to save the queen by moving
anywhere let's say Queen to f3 then we
have this finishing blow
Queen check Knight to c8 look to see a
check came to e7 and now rook to e8 is a
checkmate
okay now let's see what happens if you
open in place Bishop captures f3 or
Bishop to a5 in either case surrendering
the bishop pair and giving by a very
good slight advantage
the first more I want to consider this
Bishop to fi
well after that white move is very
obvious white has to play g4 and now
Bishop to g6 enter into the tricky area
so the only good move over here is
Bishop to e6 Callie note Bishop to d7 is
a big time blunder the simple reason is
after the moon g5 and night to g8 white
once again trapped this Queen after
Knight to d5 after Bishop to e6 white
get the bishop pair with the Moon Knight
to g5 because if he tried to save this
with the move Bishop to d7 then black
has lost it so many tempos as I have
lighted over here and this gives
wonderful initiative to the white after
the move Bishop to g2 for example a
simple line can run like this at 6
Knight to e4 castle on the Queen side
and after castle on the Queen side you
can already compare this to stupid
Bishop with this to wonderful Bishop
which are already looking at the Queen
side it is very obvious that it is only
white who is in charge of the kale the
second move Bishop captures f3 is a big
time Constitution as I have already
mentioned earlier because not only black
has surrendered his bishop pair but the
resulting position is quite favorable to
the white now just to illustrate the
plan of the campaign from the white side
I like to show you one of my game where
my opponent continued with the MU Castle
on the Queen side now instead of castle
on the Queen side like and play this
tricky move defer which happens in two
three games but here I think what should
not be afraid and take this pawn because
after the following line Knight captures
Queen captures and now black reveal his
nasty idea with the Queen check
regaining his pawn but why should not
afraid because
see three Queen captures and rook to see
one White has still obtained a very
decent advantage one of the recent game
continues with the move Bishop to e3
white continue with the move Queen check
and after Knight to e7 he liberated his
other Bishop with the move d4 black took
this pawn hitting the rope no matter
white move it out of the attack with the
move rook to be won and the following
continuation happened that is Bishop to
d3 fi Queen captures b7 f4 which at
first side looks very threatening but
White has one amazing resource which
finished the game instantly I wonder if
you can spot it kindly pause the video
and find out how as a white you should
continue from here okay I hope you find
this wonderful move we into a six so
White has a very simple threat of Bishop
to c4 and nabbing the black queen so
black doesn't have time to capture this
mission and in the game black plays King
to h8 but then comes Bishop to c1 not
only getting out of the attack but
nabbing the whole piece so defy is a
very tricky move but I can take this
pawn and maintain his very good
advantage let's concentrate on my game
whereby opponent castle on the Queen
side which is the natural move against
this I'm recommending that you should
also castle on the Queen side and Black
has to sort out the issue of his dark
squared Bishop kindly note g6 at this
position is not possible the simple
reason is after Bishop to g5 Bishop to
g7 and Knight to e4 black is going to
lose a piece so that means black has to
find other way to liberate his dark
squared Bishop at this point my opponent
continue with the Moody Phi I respond
with the move d4 with the threat of
Bishop to b5 so my opponent stop it with
the MU a6 now I place another attacking
for trying to get GFI in so my opponent
has to stop it once again with the move
at six and white plays the obvious move
Bishop to g2 so already White has
completed his all piece level of man and
do bishops are looking very very good
okay my opponent continued with the move
Queen to d7 so his idea is to play
Bishop to b4 I stopped it with the move
a3 and now he would love to play Bishop
to d6 but in that case the d5 pawn will
hang so he has to forcefully play Bishop
to e7
now both the side has tried to
centralize the rook King to b1 rook to
e8 Bishop to f4 came to be 8 and now
Luke h2 even so at first sight this
looks like a very equal position but the
problem here is black is lagging a clear
plan after a long thought my opponent
continue with the move Knight to e5 so
his idea is to play Knight to c4 but
afterwards next reply that is Bishop to
e5 my opponent realized the hand he is
in a big danger because White has a
simple threat of capturing this night
and then capturing the d5 pawn and the
funny interface the c7 point is spin so
he cannot play c6 black continue with
the move Knight to c4 hitting my
pressure I responded with the move
Bishop to have fun and night to e Phi is
now not possible because after D
captures ePHI once again the d5 point
will fall so in the game he decided to
play Queen to c6 I captured his 9 and
after Queen captures i activate my rook
with the move rook to e3 so you can see
that dr. Bishop is very annoying in
spinning down the c7 square and create a
tremendous pressure on the d5 square my
opponent had enough of this nonsense
so he played King to 8 freeing up the C
pawn but I think it's too little too
late as after rook d2 even Queen to c6
white can create this forcing sequence
that is Bishop captures Bishop captures
rook captures rook captures rook
captures Queen captures and now Knight
to d5 winning upon and get a favorable
ending my strong opponent tried the move
Queen check and after King - a - he
played Queen to e6 pinning my night but
I just defend everything with the Moosey
fall and now indeed there is a threat of
night to c7 he has to carry with the MU
King to b8 but then once again comes
this forcing sequence which gives white
a decisive advantage in the superior
endgame the forcing sequence start with
the Moon Knight captures if Queen
captures then what will simply exchange
the Queen so in the game my opponent
tried Queen captures c4 regaining his
pawn but then he has to deal with the
move Queen to b3 and after Queen
captures King captures and pawn captures
not only white king is superiorly placed
but black has some horrible pawn
structure on the Kings side the game
wrapped up very quickly after c6 d Phi K
to c7 King to d4 King to d6 and now pawn
captures pawn captures and the move b4
which completes the zukes wang scenario
he tried king g6 but that allows
infiltrating my King on the Queen side
with the moon came to see Phi King to d7
and now simple came to b6 it is just an
easy technical win for the white
I hope you enjoy and learn this
wonderful tricky set up against the
patter of defense the amazing part is
black has to decide whether he wants to
surrender the bishop pan and suffocate
slowly or play the move Bishop to h5 and
give the white full point thank you for
watching this video feel free to like
subscribe and comment on my video and
I'll meet you in my next episode very
soon bye and take care
well well well
White has this a sling bow well when
first time I seen this game I said wow
what a game man this guy has some
serious attacking potential are you
ready
have you seen this move Shakalaka boom
Bolden well personally when I gone
through this game I didn't find that
mean